Humans can distinguish between 2.3 million colors - but try to stare at this picture
Which we show through the periodic table and focused on the green dot while we reflect the colors
Do not stop staring until you say so. The light travels like a wave through our eyes,
The frequency of those wavelengths determines the apparent color of anything in this image
And around you. Humans have a tri-color vision, which means that we have three color sensors
In the retina, which receives the different wavelengths of light: blue, green, or red
Continue watching the green dot and your mind will do something funny
Has the image returned to its original colors? Although you stare at the picture in black and white
But your mind understands them as colorful.
This phenomenon is known as "the effect of the stray image". After staring for a long enough time in a differentiated color
The receptors become slowly exhausted and supply optical pigments in the sensors
The receptor begins to run out, and in the end it stops sending signals to the brain
In the case of this camouflage, the part of the image you are viewing is in heavenly color, blue and green sensors
Has become stressful and as a result there is an increase in the activity of red sensors that have not been strained yet
In the picture that turned black and white we see the celestial colors in the red
As you grow older, you are likely to have learned the basic red, yellow, and blue colors and their secondary colors
But things get harder when you see the basic colors in your printer
Are purple, yellow, and cyan and that screen you are watching now
Use the red, green and blue colors! These are different models of colors, since the "red blue green" model is "collective"
That is, blending different colors of light produces a new color, while the other triangular model is a terrestrial system
And absorbs different lengths of light
For example, when you carry a yellow thing of life actually
In fact it absorbs all wavelengths except yellow, and the color is reflected
On your eyes. But when you see something yellow across the screen in fact it is not yellow at all
Because your screen uses only red, green and blue colors
When you actually contemplate anything yellow, it will actually be a combination of
Red and green - this is because the wavelength of yellow is between red and green, our brain
Explains this combination with yellow (yellow screen) if, what you actually see is not actually
Yellow at all, but it stimulates a combination of red and green sensors,
Which your brain interprets as yellow
While the colors of plants come in a range of colors, the predominant color is green as a result of chlorophyll
The energy-absorbing pigment in the plants is necessary for photosynthesis.
So to be able to attract insects such as bees, insects and birds, flowers appeared
For excellence on green. That's why we do not see green flowers! And flowering plants
A variety of different colors have been developed to attract certain types of patches, known as
Infectious syndrome. Birds pollen red flowers, to evaporate
Visit bees, where the system of vision is different from birds
Making it difficult for them to distinguish between red and green
Similarly, each of us has a favorite color, but why? One theory suggests that preference for both colors
Based on sex, where the choice is made between the heavenly and the red, the men choose the heavenly
Women prefer reddish colors. Scientists assumed that this preference stems from
Primitive communities where the vision system in women is dedicated to the collection of red berries
Against green leaves. Another hypothesis says we love the associated grades
With fun things, all the fun and fun things have the same color
But we do not like blue mold.
Our search for colors led us to think about the connection between science and art
So in our last section we asked scientists and artists about their vision of the world
Tell us in comments about your favorite colors, and participate in more weekly science sections!